today you have laid 1 few foundation stones again
to take away the Schufa even more
the federal government the cabinet
has today brought some broadcasts on n way
on the basis of last year's court ruling by the EU
I'll explain it to you now uh what's up with all these stories
therefore best save this could be n longer video
by the way
do you actually already know my guidebook how to delete my Schufa data
if not you can find them underless Point Info
okay and what exactly is it now
so last year in december there was the verdict of the ogh regarding the Schufa
that automatic scoring violates GDPR
also that the banks,
for example,
no longer simply go beyond calling
be allowed to make their decision
Whether someone gets for example 1 credit or just not
that went now uh
not far enough with the German legislator
and that's why now they just have some changes in the law
brought on n way
around the Schufa
far-
yes to take away post positions for this scoring
and that now in detail
as I have already published in one of my videos
the Schufa needs 70 features
to make 1 scoring but we will make just 17 of them
the new legal basis now provides for
that some of these 70 different positions are deleted
where to assume
that it actually has nothing to do with it at all OB one its
Invoice can pay his rent can
yes that one is solvent the new change in the law provides for
that,
among other things,
the following things in the scoring authorization
are no longer considered
Data on your background and political opinion
Display data about your address History of data from social networks
another story that is very very delicate
Info about payments from and to bank accounts
and why the whole is actually well quite simple
you want to avoid discrimination
one is discriminated against
when you live in an area
where you can assume okay that there are many people there
are insolvent
poorer areas in Germany,
for example
and if you live there
you will simply already be rated worse because of your address
this is definitely discrimination
just like how often you somehow move
because it is discriminatory to assume
that if you move very often that it has financial reasons
it might as well be
that you simply and professionally very
very much on the road
and very well your bills and other things numbers can
it is just necessary that you move constantly and what happens now
well now this legislative proposal or these amendments has been
introduced into the Bundestag
there it is now discussed
Experts are heard Consumer protectionists are heard
Data protectionists are heard
the whole is then discussed
then it goes to the Federal Council and there it is then passed
and the most important question is of course do you get anything out of it now
well not for now that will certainly take a few months now
but after that already because you can assume that
that when these things fall away
that many of you suddenly have n much better score than before